johnny depp and amber heard's defamation
trial is over but the battle outside the
court continues welcome to entertainment
tonight nichelle turner is off but all
eyes are on depth's legal team today as
the rockstar reaction for johnny rolls
on
[Applause]
the key to victory was focusing on the
facts and the evidence i feel that
finally after six years he's gotten his
life back
[Applause]
johnny who turns 59 tomorrow signed
autographs for hundreds of fans after a
concert in northern england last night
just a few hours later his attorneys
were live on the today show and gma
hinting that johnny might let amber off
the hook for that 10.35 million dollars
in damages we have to be careful what we
say um but this was about mr depp's
reputation that was what it was about
for him
never did i myself
reach the point of the striking
misheard in any way
nor have i ever struck
any woman why do you think the jury
didn't believe her my sense is that it
had a lot to do with accountability that
johnny owned his issues and i think it
was a sharp contrast to miss heard and a
surprise twist today as savannah guthrie
kicked off her interview she revealed
her connection to the trial the quick
disclosure my husband has done
consulting work for the deaf legal team
but not in connection with this
interview savannah's husband michael
feldman is a public relations and
communications consultant amber's team
meanwhile blasted johnny's lawyers for
making the rounds quote it is as
unseemly as it is unprofessional the
johnny depp's legal team has chosen to
do a victory lap for setting back
decades of how women can be treated in
the courtroom we believe that the
verdict speaks for itself we encourage
any victim to come forward domestic
violence doesn't have a gender